>> Laura: A SPEECH TODAY
DELIVERED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP, A
GLOWING REPORT CARD HE GAVE ON
THE STATE OF THE U.S. ECONOMY.
SPEAKING TO WORKERS AT H AND K
EQUIPMENT IN PENNSYLVANIA, HE
CITED THE IMMEDIATE EFFECTS OF
THE HISTORIC TAX CUT AND WHAT
THEY DID ACROSS AMERICA.
>> President Trump: THERE HAS
NEVER BEEN A BETTER TIME TO HIRE
IN AMERICA, TO INVEST IN AMERICA
AND TO BELIEVE IN THE AMERICAN
DREAM THEN RIGHT NOW.
AMERICANS CROSSED OCEANS, TAMED
THE WILDERNESS, DUG OUT THE
PANAMA CANAL, AND LAUNCHED A MAN
ONTO THE FACE OF THE MOON.
AMERICAN HANDS AND GRIT POURED
THE CONCRETE IN OUR HIGHWAYS AND
FORGED TO THE STEEL OUR
SKYSCRAPERS.
AMERICANS DO ANYTHING, BUILD
ANYTHING AND CREATE ANYTHING AS
LONG AS WE HAVE PRIDE IN OUR
COUNTRY.
CONFIDENCE IN OUR VALUES, AND
RESPECT FOR OUR GREAT AMERICAN
FLAG.
AMERICA DOESN’T BELONG TO THE
WASHINGTON POWER BROKERS, IT
BELONGS TO YOU.
AND I THINK WE HAVE TAUGHT THEM
THAT.
>> Laura: JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION, ITS FORMER WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR ANTHONY
SCARAMUCCI.
THIS SPEECH WAS AWESOME, I KNOW
YOU HAVE ALREADY WRITTEN A PIECE
FOR "USA TODAY" CHRONICLING ALL
THE SUCCESSES THAT TRUMP HAS
HAD.
IF ANY OTHER PRESIDENT AND OTHER
PARTY HAD SUCH A YEAR OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT, THE MEDIA IT
WOULD GOING BANANAS.
>> 70% APPROVAL RATING, THEY
WOULD ALL BE CHEERING HIM.
IT’S COMMON SENSE AND ITS
POLICY, AND POLICY MATTERS.
IT’S GREAT LEADERSHIP FROM THE
BULLY PULPIT.
IT MAKES SO MUCH COMMON SENSE
AND IT’S SO COMMERCIALLY SOUND.
THAT’S THE REASON.
>> Laura: THE NEXT SEGMENT I’M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT, THIS GROUP
I TALKED TO TODAY, HEAVY
EQUIPMENT DISTRIBUTORS ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES.
UNBELIEVABLE STORIES, YOU SEE
HIM IN THOSE SETTINGS.
YOU SEE HIM WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY CREATING SOMETHING, NOT
PEOPLE WHO TALK FOR A LIVING.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY CREATING
SOMETHING, CONCRETE THINGS, THEY
KNOW WHAT IT’S LIKE TO MAKE A
PAYROLL EVERY DAY.
I LIKE HIM AND THOSE SETTINGS, I
WANT TO SEE MORE OF HIM WITH
REAL AMERICANS CREATING REAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER AMERICANS.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT THIS, ALSO
BENEFITING FROM A SPRING
LOADING, THE LAST ADMINISTRATION
WAS ANTIBUSINESS.
THERE WAS A HOARD OF CASH THAT
THE BUSINESS LEADERS WERE SAVING
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO WORRIED
ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT.
HE IS UNLEASHING GROWTH AND
REDUCING REGULATION WHICH I
WRITE ABOUT IN THE "USA TODAY"
PIECE, YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
EXTRAORDINARY GROWTH.
I THINK HE’S GOING TO SURPRISE
PEOPLE IN THE MIDTERMS.
>> Laura: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
APPLE, YOU SAID A TIM COOK HAS
SAID REALLY NEGATIVE THINGS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT, THEY SAID
THIS IS THE END OF THE TRUMP
AGENDA, THE BUSINESS COUNCIL HAS
BEEN DISBANDED?
WHO HAS BEEN BETTER FOR APPLE?
DONALD TRUMP, NOT BARACK OBAMA.
PEOPLE ARE STILL TRYING TO GIVE
OBAMA CREDIT FOR THIS PERIOD OF
20,000 APPLE JOBS.
>> THAT WILL LAST FOR A LITTLE
WHILE LONGER BUT BY THE MIDDLE
OF NEXT YEAR THERE WILL BE NO
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THE REALLY GOOD NEWS IS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, WATCH HOW
CONSUMPTION IMPROVES NOW.
LOWER MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILIES HAVE
EXTRA DISPOSABLE INCOME AND THAT
WILL SET OFF A CIRCLE AS WE TALK
ABOUT IN THE ECONOMIC WORLD.
>> Laura: ARE YOU WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT MARKETS OVERHEATED,
IT’S GOING TO COLLAPSE AND CAN’T
STAY THIS HIGH.
HOW BAD COULD THAT BE?
>> OVER 30 YEARS, ONE OF THE BIG
METRICS I LOOK AT IS THE PRICE
OF THE MARKET RELATIVE TO THE
GDP, THAT’S STARTING TO TREND A
LITTLE HIGH.
WE ARE IN THAT 175% ZONE.
THE VERY GOOD NEWS IS THEY ARE
SEEING A BIG INCREASE.
NEXT YEAR’S EARNINGS SUPPORT
CURRENT ASSET PRICES.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS.
>> Laura: YOU MENTIONED THIS
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE DON’T TALK
ABOUT IT -- THE REPATRIATION OF
CAPITAL PROFITS BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
2.5 TRILLION OVERSEAS, 311
COMPANIES.
IT’S NOW STARTING TO COME BACK.
THE FEDS SAY THEY ARE GOING TO
GET UPWARDS OF $300 BILLION IN
TAXES JUST FROM THAT
REPATRIATION.
WE ARE NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
HOW SIGNIFICANT THAT FIGURE
IS -- THAT’S WILD.
>> WHAT VIEWERS NEED TO KNOW IS
THERE A TERRIFIC MULTIPLIER
EFFECT, IT CAN BE USED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE, REBUILDING
AIRPORTS AND ROADS, THERE IS A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS THAT CAN
HAPPEN NOW AS A RESULT OF GOOD